finally the custom exclusive IndieGoGo
campaign t-shirts have come in i'm
wearing one of them today of course
we've got a major major crowdfunding
campaign going on at david pakman.com
slash donate i won't again tell you
everything that we're doing through the
campaign but we're doing some really
really tremendous stuff people have been
telling me that you can read about it at
david pakman.com slash donate two of the
perks that are available are custom
t-shirts let me tell you about the
t-shirts number one these shirts
including the one I'm wearing in the
cantaloupe color choice are made from
one hundred percent recycled materials
they are made from scraps of fabric that
have been reconstituted into a t-shirt
one hundred percent recycled materials
printed in ohio in the united states i
am wearing the hatred mail exclusive
t-shirt you can go to david pakman.com
slash donate and get this t-shirt this
is a design originally created by one of
our viewers for hatred mail segment
which airs on the program uh and this is
a version of that design which is
available at david pakman.com slash
donate you can pick the color you can
pick the size we also have another
exclusive shirt which i'm putting up on
the screen for you now this is the
established in 2005 t-shirt uh TV show
producer pat with six months old when
this t-shirt came out or rather when the
david pakman show is getting younger
he's got going younger and younger yeah
uh next time it'll be he was in his
seventh month of uh pregnancy in his
mother's womb at the time that the david
pakman show star michael my dad's I this
what he was only an idea yeah um let's
put that showed up just one more second
this is the established in 2005 david
pakman show shirt is sort of a seal
motif and you can also get this at david
pakman.com slash donate which shirt do
you like better pat you like the hatred
mail shirt better that i'm wearing or do
you like the established in 2005 shirt
better more of a classy kind of guy i
think i would go with the establish in
2005 shirt that's forming this hatred
mail shirt is more of a conversation
starter because if you walk around with
this thing and people see it just says
hey treat male you can be sure that
you want to be having interesting
conversations with people this is a
shirt that will catalyze those
conversations but you also may be
attracting yourself to a tree it's
themselves so yeah yet the yet the way
that into it may not be what we refer to
as hatred repellent that's for sure
check out all the perks including the
custom exclusive hey treat male t-shirt
at david pakman.com slash donate any
donation is much appreciated the t-shirt
perks start at 49 bucks